(intense dramatic music)
Hello and welcome to Drew Crime Mysteries,
a true crime series dedicated to mysteries surrounding
people named Drew.
I'm Keith Morrison.
People who know her say that Drew Barrymore can light up
a room; in fact, she lights up a room so much,
it's a little suspicious.
Drew is too nice.
I mean, who is that nice?
It just like, it started to concern me.
She spends entire segments of her show helping people
with stain removal.
That's not normal.
Has anybody met anybody with that much enthusiasm
about anything, about everything?
She also doesn't age, and her skin is like,
like a baby's butt.
Yeah, like a, like a baby's booty, yeah.
It's just so hard to believe someone
like her really exists, and that's when we started to think,
"What if she doesn't?"
What if Drew Barrymore isn't real?
What if Drew Barrymore doesn't exist?
I mean, I was married to her.
I don't even know if she exists.
Yes, her friends feared the worst,
but Drew Barrymore did exist or did she?
I started wondering, like, maybe she's some type
of hologram or like collective hallucination.
Maybe she's just a bunch of kittens in a human suit.
I mean, has anybody thought about that?
Or maybe, just maybe, she did exist, but had been exposed
to one too many stain removal solutions.
Perfect skin, perfect host, perfect attitude.
(chuckles) Yes, Drew Barrymore seemed a little too good
to be true.
So we put our investigative team to work.
We obtained a little bit of Drew Barrymore's DNA
and what did we discover?
Why, it was shocking.
It confirmed not only does Drew Barrymore exist,
she's one of a kind!
That's it for this edition of Drew Crime Mysteries.
Thank you for joining us.
(robotic noise)
(upbeat, inspiring music)